bonjour juste avant ça va casimir le
moral est au beau fixe voire mieux
il faut aussi françois tu tiens à super
fort contenant casimir je t'en prie ne
me bouscule pas comme ça moi je
travaillais très tard hier soir je suis
très fatigué bonjour les amis ça ça va
chez vous oui ça boume attend bien tant
mieux parce que aujourd'hui c'est une
grande surprise pour vous le clown pique
nique au bar venir ah ah ah genre il
avance
quoi mais françois tu n'avais pas
prévenus de la visite du clown pique
nique ou ben c'est normal françois
n'était pas au courant
écoute casimir étant donné que c'est moi
qui fais le qu'une pique nique au toit
quand même pu avoir la délicatesse de me
prévenir
eh bien je te préviens françois veux tu
faire le clown pique nique aux
ob oui oui évidemment évidemment puisque
tu en a parlé aux enfants il ne peut
refuser maintenant marseille c'est bien
ce que j'avais prévu une malheureusement
- casimir aujourd'hui j'ai aucune
inspiration écoute françois j'ai une
idée
tu devrais avoir un partenaire demande à
monsieur dit stop d'être le clown blanc
oui à deux vous aurez plus d'idées mais
c'est une très très bonne idée mais
regarde ça m'ennuie de le déranger il
est en train de s'entraîner à donner des
coups de chapeau pour aller à une
réception et bien moi je vais aller lui
demander
je viens avec casimir mois non stop tu
te déguiser en pique-niquant oui je sois
tranquille françois goulard tout loup
blanc à tout à l'heure
merci tous les deux bon ben je ré
fermont mon maquillage de clown c'est le
baron bien le bonjour c'est pas très bon
ça c'est par an diane bonjour même la
comtesse mais omar amiralay je veux
salut bonjour messieurs 10 couleurs
gaies parce qu'il ya qu'est ce que c'est
multi du sma bourbon joue moins casimir
est joli mais c'est la première fois que
vous ne m'appelez pas ma très chère
julie aubin pardonnez moi chers amis et
vous qui m'avez surplus dans la
répétition et j'ai été perturbé
comment me le faire pardonner c'est bien
françois prépare son numéro de pique
nique aux et ils cherchent un clown
blanc alors ce sera vous je regrette
casimir mais jamais de la fille que je
ferai le pitre attention par le petit
train le clown le pitre ici c'est moi ça
c'est bien vrai et bien topic a dit mir
nous allons demander au facteur aux
facteurs
on attend réveillez-vous facteurs allez
vous avez réveillé j'étais en train de
faire un joli rêve oui j'avais du visage
tout blanc et puis un petit chapeau
pointu prendre avait réveillé en pour
sûr c'est pas gentil ça ça alors nous
venions justement vous demander de faire
le clown blanc avec françois
mais oui factor vous avez fait un rêve
prémonitoire que qu'est ce que c'est que
ça enlève un peu de mon tiroir est
prévenu et bien c'est quand on rêve
voilà c'est quand on rêve la nuit
quelque chose qui arrive le lendemain
par exemple le facteur vient de rêver
qu'il était en clown blanc vient
justement de lui demander de faire un
clown blanc va coûter je suis désolé
julien
mais pour ce qui est de faire le clown
je ne peux pas je peux pas ça mais
pourquoi facteurs ben pourquoi pas ce
que j'ai l'air d'un fiers-à-bras comme
ça d'un audacieux vont aller en réalité
moi je suis un grand timide
c'est vrai j'ai un grand timide que de
faire le clown là ça je sens que ça va
me donner le traquenard
[Musique]
quoi ben non non juillan non pas moi
alors non ça non je ne ferai jamais le
clown blanc et pourquoi pas pourquoi
parce que parce que parce que je suis
aux anges
[Musique]